se todos nós sabemos da importância do
meio ambiente e dos recursos naturais
para a nossa sobrevivência
qual o motivo de destruirmos a casa que
a gente vive
essa é uma pergunta que sempre me
intrigou muito e vem motivando desde a
minha infância eu cresci rodeado pela
paisagem catarinense
mais tarde pela paisagem pernambucana e
esse contato íntimo com a natureza
sempre chegou e me motivou mais tarde a
escolher uma profissão como bióloga na
biologia foi perceber quanto mais eu
estudava as plantas a natureza e os
outros organismos que prova conta de
responder àquela minha pergunta inicial
eu ia precisar mudar o meu foco para o
ser humano e que era ali que encontrar
um campo fértil para desenvolver todas
as perguntas que eu tinha pensando nisso
eu fui atrás de mestrado onde eu fiz um
mergulho nas ciências sociais um
mestrado em globalização e o desenvolveu
uma pesquisa onde eu estudei a campanha
de vacinação brasileira contra h1n1 ou a
gripe a que aconteceu em 2009
era um momento de bastante tensão
política internacional diante de uma
nova gripe que ainda era desconhecida e
eu estava bastante interessada e
entender porque tinha sido escolhido
como um dos pilares da campanha o ator
marco nanini que na época vivia o
personagem lineu um agente sanitário no
programa já extinta grande família que
muito intrigada com a escolha de um ator
que não tinha relação nenhuma aparente
com saúde para fazer parte de uma
campanha tão importante e tão relevante
o que eu percebi é que apesar de as
pessoas saberem inconscientemente que o
marco nanini era uma pessoa real e que o
lineu era um personagem de ficção
lamento que o marco nanini aparecia na
campanha e conscientemente as pessoas
associavam aquela imagem
há valores que remetiam à saúde a uma
pessoa que valorizavam a família a
comunidade a higiene é uma pessoa
correta que se afastava da mentira de
tudo que era sujo de tudo que era sólido
isso me deixou bastante intrigada a
maneira que o inconsciente absorve as
informações do mundo real
isso ao mesmo tempo que é bastante
fascinante também é bastante perigoso
a mídia muitas vezes se apropria dessas
manobras quando elabora campanhas
publicitárias quando quer empurrar seja
um produto ou uma idéia e se isso é um
fato inegável é importante que a gente
entenda como esses processos funcionam
para tentar se deixar enganar um pouco
menos
esse estudo de mestrado abriu meus olhos
para um campo que até então não conhecia
que a área da comunicação e eu continue
essa investigação no doutorado
interdisciplinar em ambiente e sociedade
no pan
aqui na unicamp e o que eu percebi é que
por trás de hábitos negativos como jogar
lixo no chão desperdiçar a água jogar
comida no lixo
havia muito mais do que uma mera falta
de informação
hoje em dia informação tom muito mais
acessível graças à internet graças a
redes sociais
nós recebemos uma avalanche de área de
informações e precisamos fazer um
esforço consciente para afastar essas
informações um pouco e ter cinco minutos
de paz por dia para tomar um café
sossegado
então o problema não é a falta de
informação
essa idéia de que mais informação
resultaria em mais atitude e mais
resultados e mais educação
são é uma teoria da comunicação que se
chama modelo do déficit e ela já foi
abandonada há algum tempo para dar um
exemplo de como essas
essas mensagens no nosso inconsciente
pode modificar os nossos hábitos
eu quero citar um estudo feito pelo
doutor jonas um chute da universidade de
cornell onde eu passei uma temporada de
um ano em 2013
o doutor chutes estava interessado em
entender o que as pessoas pensam sobre
as mudanças climáticas eo aquecimento
global e mais ainda ele estava
interessado em entender de que maneira
se o ambiente externo poderia interferir
nossas percepções e ele fez na sequência
de estudos eu vou citar dois que eu acho
bastante representativos
ele convocou uma série de estudantes que
não saberiam do que se tratava o estudo
que eles iam participar e os dividiu em
dois grupos diferentes
um grupo é colocar em uma sala com uma
temperatura mais elevada e outro grupo
foi colocado em uma sala com a
temperatura mais baixa e ele então fez a
pergunta você acredita no aquecimento
global e as pessoas que haviam sido
colocados em uma sala com a temperatura
mais quente tiveram uma tendência
significativamente maior de acreditar no
aquecimento global diferente daquelas
pessoas que estavam na sala fria
isso pode parecer uma bobagem mas o
ambiente externo influenciou uma opinião
que talvez nem tivesse sido formulada
naquele momento que talvez já viesse de
antes mas naquele momento aqueles
estudantes foram influenciados em outra
etapa do estudo
ele recrutou novos estudantes dividiu
novamente em dois grupos e dessa vez ele
ofereceu uma bala de canela para um
grupo e para o outro
nada foi o grupo controle eu acho que aí
você já entender onde isso vai dar o
grupo que ingeriu uma bala de canela
também teve uma tendência
significativamente maior de acreditar no
aquecimento global
isso é muito interessante e nos mostra
que a maneira como as informações são
internalizados muitas vezes são mais
importante é mais importante do que a
quantidade de informações que a gente
recebe um outro exemplo de pegadinha
cognitiva o chamado efeito bumerangue
esse efeito ocorre quando acontece o
efeito oposto ao efeito desejado
um exemplo bastante clássico imediato
são as campanhas anti tabagistas quando
muitas vezes aquela imagem do cigarro
provoca o desejo maior de fumar do que
sua campanha não existisse o que eu acho
interessante disso tudo eu quero agora
retomar a minha pergunta inicial porque
nós insistimos em destruir o nosso
próprio planeta e para isso também eu
gostaria de dar mais um exemplo que diz
respeito à maneira como nós
internalizamos o ambiente em que vivemos
que diz respeito à nossa dimensão ea
nossa percepção do tempo ser humano tem
uma dificuldade muito grande de lidar
com escala de tempo que vai além de
algumas décadas que é a experiência
direta que a maioria de nós tem com o
tempo
uma prova disso é a nossa percepção de
que a cada ano o ano acaba mais rápido
de que a cada ano o ano passa mais
rápido
isso tem uma explicação muito simples
que vai além da correria da
pós-modernidade
um bebê de 1 ano e 1 ano representa 100
por cento de toda a experiência de vida
que ele já teve um bebê de dois anos um
ano passa a ser 50% da experiência dele
aos 10 anos um ano representa 10% e
assim sucessivamente
por isso quando nós lemos uma reportagem
que diz que em 80 anos as geleiras vão
derreter ou que em 2050 recife e rio de
janeiro vão sumindo do mapa
o nosso cérebro simplesmente não
consegue
internalizar essa informação de uma
maneira realista de uma maneira que nos
motive a provocar uma mudança real nos
nossos hábitos e são esses tipos de
manobras
esse tipo de pegadinha cognitiva esse
tipo de internalização das informações
que nós temos que ter em mente quando
divulgamos informações científicas
quando divulgamos informações sobre meio
ambiente e quando buscamos mobilizar a
sociedade para as grandes questões
ambientais do nosso tempo
a comunicação está no centro da solução
obrigada